FIVE" WELL, THAT WAS A LITTLE
WEIRD AFFAIR LAST NIGHT.
IT WAS LESS OF A DEBATE AND MORE
OF A FAMILY SQUABBLE IN FRONT OF
THE NEIGHBORS.
>> IF WE'RE GOING TO FORCE
AMERICANS TO MAKE THE RADICAL
CHANGES, THEY'RE NOT -- THROW
YOUR HANDS UP.
YOU HAVEN'T --
>> ALSO MENTION --
>> EVERY CREDIBLE POLL THAT I
HAVE SEEN HAS ME BEATING DONALD
TRUMP.
>> HILLARY CLINTON WAS WINNING
IN THE POLLS, TOO.
>> WHO IS OFFERING A FALSE
CHOICE HERE?
>> YOU HAVE SOME.
>> I THINK DEMOCRATS WIN WHEN WE
RUN ON REAL SOLUTIONS, THINGS
THAT ARE WORKABLE, NOT FAIRY
TALE ECONOMICS.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
ANYBODY WOULD GO THROUGH THE
TROUBLE OF RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND JUST TO
TALK ABOUT THING WE SHOULDN'T
FIGHT FOR.
>> Greg: LET'S BRING THE GROUP
COUNSELLING INSIDE.
IT'S MAKING THE KIDS AND DOGS
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THANK GOD THERE WAS A THERAPIST
ON HAND TO MAKE THINGS BETTER OR
WORSE.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE TRUMP
VOTERS THAT PRIORITIZE THE
ECONOMY OVER THE PRESIDENT'S
BIGOTRY?
>> Greg: NO BIAS THERE.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HALF THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE RACISTS?
NO WONDER CNN IS BLEEDING
VIEWERS.
THE DEBATE CAME DOWN TO A
THREE-PART EPISODE, A LEFT WING
CANDIDATE EXPLAIN HOW SOMETHING
EVERYTHING CAN BE FREE.
AND THEN SOMEONE SHOUTS EVIL
TRUMP.
THANK GOD MISS CLEO SHOWED UP.
>> IF YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
DEAL WITH THIS DARK PSYCHIC
FORCE OF THE COLLECTIVE HATRED
THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS BRINGING
UP IN THIS COUNTRY, I'M AFRAID
THE DEMOCRATS WILL SEE SOME DARK
DAYS.
>> Greg: LOVE HER OR HATE HER,
SHE HAS TWO THINGS IN COMMON
WITH TRUMP.
SHE'S NO POLITICIAN AND SHE HAS
A POINT OF VIEW.
JUST DON'T ASK HER ABOUT HER
PET.
>> DO YOU HAVE A PET?
>> DO I HAVE A PET?
I HAVE A CAT AND IT DIED.
>> Neil: THAT AIN'T NO
POLITICIAN'S ANSWER.
SHE WASN'T THE ONLY ONE WITH
TRUMP ON THE BRAIN.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> TRUMP IS A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR.
>> THAT'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO
BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP DISGRACES THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> WE HAVE TO GET RID OF DONALD
TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE SYMPTOM
OF A DISEASE.
>> DONALD TRUMP, DONALD TRUMP.
>> LET'S GET REAL.
TONIGHT WE DEBATE BUT ULTIMATELY
WE HAVE TO BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: MAYBE IT'S ME BUT THAT
TALK ABOUT TRUMP MAKES HIM MORE
ALLURING.
IT'S LIKE WHEN DAD SAYS STAY
AWAY FROM THE MAGAZINES AT THE
BARBER SHOP.
WE SAY LET'S CHECK OUT THE
MAGAZINES.
JUAN LAUGHED AT THAT.
IT'S WEIRD HOW TEN PEOPLE
TALKING TRASH ABOUT YOU MAKES
YOU SEEM SO MUCH BIGGER.
YET TRUMP LOOMED OVER THE DEBATE
LIKE THE DEVIL IN THE EXORCIST.
NO COMFORTABLE CAME FROM THE
ROOM BUT NO CANDIDATE EITHER.
DANA, I SAW ONE OF YOUR TWEETS
LAST NIGHT.
YOU DO THAT THINGS WHERE YOU --
I NOTICE NOT ONLY WHAT WAS THERE
BUT WHAT WASN'T THERE.
WHAT WASN'T MENTION, DANA?
>> Dana: CNN, I PRAISE THEM FOR
STARTING THE DEBATE AT 8:00 P.M.
WHAT WASN'T THERE IS THE TRUTH
THAT IT WAS THREE HOURS LONG,
NOT TWO HOURS LONG.
>> Greg: YOU SAID THERE WAS NO
MENTION OF IMPEACHMENT AND NO
COLLUSION.
>> Dana: AND NO SEND HER BACK.
THAT WAS A BIG THING.
AND NO BIDEN.
NOBODY MENTIONED ANY OF THOSE
THINGS THAT WON'T BE THE CASE
TONIGHT WHEN BIDEN IS ON THE
STAGE.
THE OTHER THING THAT YOU
MENTIONED, MARYANN HAS THAT
TRUMP HAS, SHE ALSO HAS A
FOLLOWING.
A READY-MADE FOLLOWING.
THEY'VE BEEN FOLLOWING HER FOR
DECADES.
IT'S NOT THE SAME CROWD THAT
FOLLOWED PRESIDENT TRUMP IF YOU
FOLLOWED HIM IN NEW YORK.
MARYANN IS AN INTERNATIONAL STAR
AS WELL.
SHE IS CONFOUNDING DEMOCRATS A
LITTLE BIT.
WHY DOES SHE HAVE THIS SUPPORT?
WHERE IS IT COMING FROM?
SHE'S BEEN BUILDING IT FOR
YEARS.
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE'S
SAYING.
SHE WAGING A PSYCHOLOGICAL
BATTLE.
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE PSYCHE
OF THE NATION.
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE FAMILY
FEUD LAST NIGHT BETWEEN THE
MODERATES AND THE NOT MODERATES?
>> FIRST, I LISTENED TO YOUR
MONOLOGUE WITH SUCH INTEREST.
THEN I HEARD ABOUT MISS CLEO.
ISN'T SHE -- WAS SHE A BLACK
WOMAN ON TV?
>> Greg: A PSYCHIC.
1-800 NUMBER.
>> THAT WAS IT.
YOU HAVE TO DIAL 1-800.
SO NOW YOU GET MARYANN.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE GETS THE
WHITE HOUSE.
SHE GOT LOTS OF ATTENTION.
I READ SHE WAS THE MOST SEARCHED
PERSON ON THE STAGE IN TERMS OF
GOOGLING AND THE LIKE.
SO PEOPLE ARE LIKE WHO IS SHE?
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
I THINK SOME OF YOU KNOW WHO SHE
IS.
I DON'T KNOW WHO SHE IS.
POLITICALLY SHE'S A NOBODY.
IT'S A LITTLE STUNNER.
I GET THE WHOLE TRUMP ANALOGY.
BUT AT SOME POINT, WOULD SHE
FALL OFF THE STAGE FOR THE NEXT
ROUND?
APPARENTLY NOT.
>> Dana: SHE HAS A FOLLOWING.
>> Greg: ANYBODY -- YOU THOUGHT
OF THE GROUP THAT WASN'T
STRONGEST?
>> Juan: CLEARLY ELIZABETH
WARREN CAME STRONGEST AND LEFT
STRONGEST.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY DID ANY
DAMAGE TO HER.
TO ME, THE WHOLE NOTION THAT
IT'S A FAMILY FEUD.
THAT'S HEALTHY.
WE SHOULD BE SEEING A DEBATE
THAT HELPS DETERMINE WHO THE
CANDIDATE IS.
LOOK BACK TO 2016.
REPUBLICANS WERE MORE DIVIDED.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE WALL.
THERE WAS ONE GUY UP THERE THAT
SAID YEAH, THE WALL IS A GREAT
IDEA.
TRADE, FOREIGN TRADE.
WAR IN IRAQ.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T TELL THE
TRUTH BUT HE SAID THAT HE HAD
OPPOSED THE WAR IN IRAQ.
>> Greg: HE KIND OF DID.
DIRECTIONALLY TOLD THE TRUTH.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT IT WAS A
SUBSTANTIVE DEBATE ABOUT
MEDICARE FOR ALL, THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH DELANEY PLAYING
THE FOIL TO SANDERS AND WARREN
MAKING SOME REAL GOOD POINTS AND
FORCING THEM TO DEFEND THEIR
POINTS.
WHEN HE SPOKE ABOUT THE COSTS --
>> Greg: WE'RE GOING DO DO THAT
IN THE B BLOCK.
>> Jesse: YOU CALLED IT A
SQUABBLE, A FEUD.
I CALL IT A REINCONVENIEN
I CALL IT A REINVENVENIEN
I CALL IT A REINVENTENIEN
I CALL IT A REINVENTIOIEN
I CALL IT A REINVENTION.
BERNIE AND WARREN ARE LIGHTING
THEMSELVES ON FIRE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S LIKE THE REALISTS, THIS
WILL GET US KILLED IN A
LANDSLIDE.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THE AUDIENCE CLAPS EVERY TIME
SOME SOCIALIST SAYS SOMETHING
CRAZY.
>> Juan: IT'S POPULAR.
>> Jesse: SOCIALISM IS POPULAR.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> Jesse: SO WERE CULTS IN THE
70s.
SOMETHING IS POPULAR DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S GOOD.
RIGHT NOW WHAT IS HAPPENING,
WARREN, I DISAGREE.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS FRENETIC.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS ANNOYING.
SHE FAILED THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TEST WHEN SHE
TOOK THE FIRST NUKE STRIKE
OPTION OFF THE TABLE.
LIKE SHE'S GOING TO SACRIFICE AN
AMERICAN CITY AND LET NORTH
KOREA THROW A MISSILE OVER HERE.
THEN RESPOND AFTER WE LOST
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
SHE REFUSED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER SHE WOULD
RAISE TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
BERNIE IS A NOTHING IN
WASHINGTON HIS WHOLE CAREER.
HE ONLY KNOWS HOW TO TAKE.
HE'S A RAGEAHOLIC.
NOBODY HAD ANY SENSE OF HUMOR.
MARYANN WILLIAMSON, SHE'S LIKE
HOMEOPATHIC THERAPY.
EVERYONE IS ON STAGE IS LIKE
ADVIL AND ASPIRIN.
SHE'S LIKE YOGA AND CBD OIL.
BUT SHE'S TAPPED INTO SOME REAL
ENERGY IN THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK THAT ENERGY IS
FULLY FORMED YET.
SHE'S GOT INTO IT.
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT YOU, EMILY?
YOUR HIGHLIGHTS AND LOW LIGHTS.
>> I AGREE WITH PART OF WHAT YOU
SAID.
IT WAS LIKE A HUNGER GAMES BIG
FISH IN A SMALL POND.
THE PROGRESSIVES WON.
BERNIE EMERGED AS THE COMMANDER
AND HE AND ELIZABETH WERE THE
PROS, BUT THEY FAILED AT THE
COMMANDER LEVEL.
I AGREE.
TO ME, IT WAS CLEAR THE
PROGRESSIVES WON.
AT WHAT COST TO THE PARTY, AT
WHAT COST TO THE REALITY OF THE
MODERATE SECTION, WHICH IS WAS
ECLIPSED.
THE AH-HAH MOMENTS AND THE
ZINGERS GOT ALL THE APPLAUSE AND
EXCITEMENT.
IN REALITY, VOTERS WERE LIKE, I
WOULD LIKE MORE INFO FROM THAT
MODERATE OVER THERE AND I WOULD
LIKE MORE AIR TIME FROM THAT
MODERATE OVER THERE.
SO TO ME, IT WAS AN ANALOGY OF
CNN TAKING AWAY THE CHOICE FROM
THE VOTER AT HOME.
>> Dana: YOU COULDN'T GET FULL
ANSWERS BECAUSE THE RULES THAT
THEY HAD SET OUT HAD THE
MODERATORS WERE FORCED TO CUT
OFF EVERYBODY JUST AS THEY WERE
ABOUT TO MAKE A POINT, CUT THEM
OFF.
>> Greg: YEAH.
I THOUGHT 2/3s OF THE MODERATORS
DID A GOOD JOB.
I THOUGHT THAT THEY MUST HAVE
BEEN CRINGING WITH LEMON
EDITORIALIZING, WAS A BIT ODD.
IT'S LIKE HAVING ME UP THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: TRUMP WENT AFTER LEMON.
HE WAS IN SELF-DEFENSE MODE.
TWO OUTSTANDING MOMENTS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
ELIZABETH WARREN SAID TO THE
MODERATES THAT THEY'RE MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
WHY ARE YOU RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT TO TELL US WHAT WE
CAN'T DO?
THE OTHER ONE IS MAYOR PETE
SAYING, OH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE PUBLIC IS GOING TO CALL YOU
SOCIALIST IF YOU'RE LIBERAL OR
CONSERVE
CONSERATIV
CONSERVATIVE.